Welcome to ABE Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Hello everyone.
Brent is not here.
He's putting the final touches on some redecorating for Satya.
Satya is actually redoing an entire ballroom with an underground bunker in his East Wing.
Brent is in charge of installing 1,000 Nvidia cards in there to control Satya's disco light
show.
So that's almost done.
In the meantime, I have a much better guest than Brent.
Brent who has been on fewer podcasts, actually Brent and I are recording this week, those
of you listening.
But in the meantime, I have someone better.
Molly Sheets is here.
Molly, say hi to everyone and we can get going here.
Hi, I'm Molly Sheets.
I'm was a director of engineering and now I'm kind of figuring out what my next steps
are.
I'm still in engineering now.
Yeah, we'll call it.
I called mine my mini retirement.
Yeah, yeah.
When it's not, when it's a loosely intentional sabbatical and not really, you're like,
yeah, how long am I going to be in this for, especially if you get bored?
I took, I took, of course, I quit my job at NBC, which I've talked about that
before.
Wasn't a great fit because I care about software and people and I, and I, I hiked the Pacific
Crest Trail last year.
And then when I was in the middle of the Sierra in California, early June waiting
through snow, I said to my and being dive bombed by mosquitoes, I told myself I would
like to go back here and hike with no snore mosquitoes.
And I just got back a few days ago from my trip on the John Muir Trail.
210 or 220 miles or so of that overlaps with the PCT.
But I hiked through the Sierra.
There was no snow.
There were two mosquitoes the whole trip and it was fun.
And now I'm home and reality is hard.
I'd rather live in the woods.
I know.
Can can I just my next job is living under a rock.
That would be great.
Yeah.
Anyone who's close to retirement, I'm like, dang it.
I got to figure this out for, you know, 15 more years.
Just if I'm lucky, just in this economy, it's easy.
Just make a lot of money and save over half of it and you can retire in 10 years.
I was reading.
So my house is almost paid off, which is like amazing.
Right.
But as I'm looking for a next gig, one of the usually I get rolled out at the
you're at Atlanta.
Oh, we're not.
Can you move?
No, not even a question.
I'm not like that.
Have you seen interest rates?
I literally would rather be jobless for a year than move based on how the math works
financially to move to somewhere like California or Seattle and the risk in this market of
how do I know if the employer is going to keep me around in six months?
Right.
It is such a big risk to move.
Yeah.
It's gorgeous.
Seattle.
It's expensive here.
It is gorgeous, though.
I was just talking for two.
Yeah.
For two months out of the year, it's gorgeous and the rest of time it's gray and dark.
This is why I leave Seattle to go nicer places sometimes.
So someday I think retire in retirement, especially when I get there, I will probably
visit Seattle often in the summer and live somewhere nicer the rest of the time.
That's my plan.
You know what I realized?
We haven't done an intro on how you and I have met.
Oh, why would we even be talking a little bit behind the scenes?
Yeah.
Why?
Who is Molly?
And why is she here?
And even more behind the scenes, we tried this podcast a month ago and then there
was user error on my part and I could and the recording is actually recording
this time.
We had a great conversation.
Probably the best conversation we've ever had ever in the history of the podcast.
And it's not recorded and only Molly and I will know.
So Molly and I met.
I worked at, I think, I worked at a game engine and ads company.
I think ads made more money than the game engine.
You worked at Unity Technologies for a while.
And Molly was a you weren't a Tim.
You were you.
What was what was your role?
I was a principal solutions architect.
OK.
Molly was our was our key Amazon partner.
We had a lot of meetings together and I felt really bad for Molly as you know,
you tried to screw you know, you tried to screw over by trying to.
This is all I don't have any NDAs.
Unity had no intention of changing from our sweet deal at GCP to Amazon,
but they wanted Amazon to bend over backwards and put together a deal so we
could have more leverage for for Google.
And Molly, unfortunately,
did all that work in like in very, very long hours.
And I couldn't tell her, even though, like my conscious, like, tell her,
tell her and tell her to make shit up.
And but anyway, we bonded over some
awkward glances in meetings, in Zoom meetings.
And and the rest is history.
Yes, yes, it built character.
I honestly, you know, big opportunities,
you know, there's going to be a losing party.
Right. And yeah, I think it was it was good for me.
The line that I would draw was on my side.
There was a time where I was like on at a dining
dining, doing sushi with my husband.
And I got a call from one of our VPs at Amazon and they were like,
you have to join this call.
And I'm like, I am at dinner.
Oh, my God.
And they're like, yeah, but you've got to come.
And I'm like, damn it.
It was like that kind of, you know, stress.
And that's when you that's when you start to think
when everyone's telling you like, oh, you need to have work life balance.
I'm like, yes. But what if I draw the boundary
and the boundary just keeps getting crossed?
And then you're told it's you.
And I'm like, well, what if it's not?
That's that's how I felt about that.
But, you know, it's all good. It's all good.
I grew from it.
Yeah, incidentally, I don't know the name and don't ask me to look it up,
but I don't follow them.
But I was scrolling Instagram the other day and you know how they are.
If you pause too long on something, they show you more of that.
And so I'm now apparently shadow following
this guy who he collects text between employees and their managers
on managers as being really shitty and asking you to join a call
like in the middle of dinner.
Oh, I think I know you're talking about
there was one that was like someone's parent died or something.
And they were trying to ask for time off.
And they were like, do you have a proof?
Right, right. It's just all kinds of like, oh, my God.
Why are people with absolutely zero ounces of empathy managing people?
Yet it happens.
And it happens in everything from fast food to tech to politics,
which we'll talk about one of those three at least today.
Yeah. Why is it so intermingled right now
as a whole other thing?
Politics and tech is is almost a circle.
It's not a Venn diagram anymore.
It's yeah.
Well, OK, back on topic here.
I know a lot about you.
You've been I'm so impressed with what you do and how
you just you've done some really cool stuff.
So what's your story?
What's what's your origin story?
Oh, do we want to go back that far as far as you want?
Just give us some context.
Sounds like Alan's talking to his friend, Molly.
And who is she and started off in film?
Then the iPhone came out,
released iPhone games and flash games for an advert
gaming company early on in my career when that was great.
And then Flash kind of died.
And that's when I started my adventure of creating my own business.
Ran that for six and a half years, sold a bunch of cloud
kind of work and decided, wow, why am I managing two businesses
under one roof and went and bought out the board,
joined Amazon as a principal solutions architect
and did what we just talked about.
Then I went to Zenga, which was acquired by Take Two after Amazon,
because they were investing in Kubernetes.
And I like to run at hard problems.
I decided, yeah, that was the hard hardest problem.
I actually was really scared of it as a technology while I was at Amazon.
It was like the thing that I never would make time to learn.
And so afterward, I was feeling really guilty and said, OK,
you need to sit down and learn this.
Yeah, my first question, my first question to
a team who wants to move, who wants to go on and Kubernetes is,
do you really need Kubernetes?
No, not always.
Yeah, it's so funny, too, because they were like,
you're a director of Kubernetes.
I said, I was director of Kubernetes because they had a Kubernetes team.
And most people don't.
And like, especially now with AI, it's gotten really crazy
because build whatever you can manage most easily.
And that's changing as people become like more product minded,
people become more engineering minded people and vice versa.
So, yeah, you don't you definitely don't need a Kubernetes
unless you've got 400 applications that are on individual EC2.
What a great segue, because in
in this world that is still changing fast
underneath us with AI assisted coding and AI assisted everything.
What do we need?
Like, what's like we've we've talked about this a little bit before,
but I think it's worth talking about how is like,
do we need people to know how to write code anymore?
They need systems thinkers.
And but the spoiler, I agree.
I think you and I are going to agree on a lot of this, although there's also
I'm trying to keep an open mind about quite a bit of it, too, right?
Because it's changing so fast.
But the one thing that I feel a little guilty about in saying that
is that I'm in the last three weeks.
I've been building a game on the side because why not have time?
I'm job hunting.
And of course, it's fun.
And I decided to build it in Rust in Tori.
I was like, I'm not going to build it in a game engine.
Let's use Tori.
It's a secure platform that wraps React and lets you ship on desktop using Rust.
And I'm sitting here being like, I have no idea if that was a good idea.
Why? Because I've never written a line of Rust in my life.
And I'm not sure that I feel good about that.
So I was cool with the system, but I can't read the code
and I could read it if it was in Python or C sharp.
So what do you think about that?
I took some time to learn a little bit of Rust during the pandemic when I was bored.
And I love that there are people that know how to write in Rust.
I'm not one of them.
So it is an interesting language.
I think it's really powerful, too.
I just never wrap my head around it.
So before this being a good idea.
Well, I don't I don't know.
This is the this is probably a bad one.
Maybe we don't know.
And this is maybe one of the inherent problems using AI to help with anything.
Coding, writing, whatever, is that
we in general put more trust in it than we should.
I mean, the code compiles and runs.
It must be fine.
We don't know.
And, you know, one of the things that came up in a lot of
in my job searching interviews was we're in this is common knowledge across the
industry is we're generating code faster than humans can review it.
So humans can't review all the code.
OK, now what do we do?
And we are letting
agents and AI create a lot of shipping code for us.
And I just wrote a blog post on
last week on Metta's
layoffs and the effects in there.
And with velocity is coming some
some failure modes.
And I'll put it that way.
And the challenge this is this is very much a systems thinking problem because
I could, you know, I could also write a game in Rust
and we could try and create the same game.
But the thing about a non deterministic system creating this for us
is that you and I, even with the exact same spec, can create
vastly different implementations very fast.
Yeah. And I
we're not taking that into account when we're trying to accelerate ourselves with AI.
There are a lot of things changing at once.
Writing code is faster is too fast, almost, but yet not fast enough at the same time.
And we want systems, we want to use AI to develop systems to help us
review this code and make sure it's good.
And they're not working yet either.
And in our last podcast, it was too long ago.
Sorry, listeners.
Brent and I were talking about the
the move towards less general AI and more very specific AIs.
And then he made the same argument that, well, I can't.
AI doesn't build for scale and reliability.
I said, well, why not?
It certainly could just be a different AI engine.
So we now have I think you and I have talked about this before.
I want you to elaborate on it is
going back to my question on do we need developers?
I think we need developers who are systems thinkers.
I agree.
But they are basically also managers of and it's OK.
You can treat them badly.
They are managers of teams, agents doing different things.
They have to know which agents to employ.
And I'm curious what you think about that move.
Are developers becoming managers of agents or should they be
are we moving in that direction or by the time we get there,
is that going to be outdated?
And I think I think it's a mix of spectrum and development and agents,
because when I think of agents, their purpose,
they're defined with a specific purpose.
Sure, they're still nondeterministic in a lot of ways
because of just how tokens work with the models.
But, you know, you design an agent to do one specific thing.
Like this agent is going to be my job search agent
just because I built one.
So I might as well explain what that one is.
And that's what it does.
It searches the Internet for like a company's name
and tries to scrape layoffs and all of that data about a company
so that I can read it before going into an interview.
That's an agent versus a spec is like I sat down and wrote the design of this.
And I feel like we need equal time on both
because the spec is going to evolve, right?
Potentially.
Well, no, it should.
That's another thing that's come up in my interviews is
everybody's into, you know, it's a different spec driven development
than we used 15 years ago.
It's the one where we feed the AI of the spec.
But specs were incomplete and ambiguous
as long as I've been in software and they haven't gotten any better.
I've definitely I'll write out something.
I'll be like, I thought of every corner and then the AI will be like,
so I want to talk to you about these gaps like shit.
At least you knew to ask the question rather than
assume the spec is the all encompassing truth.
Yeah. And there are agents to your point about that of
this agent is supposed to question me.
This agent is supposed to give me feedback and it's supposed to
any spec I give it is supposed to to analyze it.
Throw darts at it.
But I think there's even systems thinking going into even
knowing that you need those things.
Yes. I think a lot of people just use Claude.
Claude, make me this code to do black.
It compiles and it runs.
They go, yay.
So is it systems thinking or is it patients?
Don't we have a whole world telling us to be impatient right now?
And what we actually need
is patience to sit down and do.
I'm lazy about this, too, because I'm like, I just want to build
the feature in the game.
I don't want to go build the agent that checks the feature.
I just want to start playing.
And yeah, we need to some thinkers, but we also need patience to come back.
I'm not convinced that patience is a different.
I would say that patience is an aspect of systems thinking
because you need to.
I mean, the part of the system is recognizing that you need to take
a step back and and think about all the bits.
Yes, I agree. I agree.
So should we teach it?
Should we get rid of heaven?
I think I read an article a while back now.
I may be imagining it that some universities are
reducing or eliminating their computer science degrees
or their software engineering degrees if they have them, because
we have all these computer science people graduating
that can't get jobs because they've been replaced.
Airquilt replaced by AI.
So what do we need to teach?
Like if I'm in university and my son just graduated with a sociology degree,
which is much, much smarter than computer science, we'll see what he does with it.
I think, well, in my opinion, I think sociology is a much better degree
to get today than computer science.
But do we have to?
Here's a system thinking part.
Part of me is going to ask, do we have should we change
what we're teaching our young people to do?
Or is it changing so fast underneath us that that nothing is right?
Do we go for these single monolithic degrees anymore?
Or do we create a bunch of like smaller degrees
that you can kind of pick and form, become your own generalist person?
That's it's just a bunch of minors, minor degrees.
That's kind of what I was thinking.
Yeah, because you're never going to find the right way to package it.
I think to know there is an advantage these days of knowing a lot about a little.
Yes. And.
But boy, it's a changing world.
So what's do you want to talk a little bit about what we start?
I went back to your origin story and it got the high level, but.
Oh, I want to talk about your blog.
Oh, OK, we can talk about me.
It's fine. It's all about me.
Part of the origin. So. Oh, OK.
I had an itch to write.
I used to write a while ago and you've gone through like ups and downs of writing.
And when I left Amazon, one of the reasons I started writing
is because I just had so much I wanted to write about.
And the reason I do it is is more of a therapeutic.
I want to get it out of my head. I can't meet you.
I process by writing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It helps me think through problems.
And I'm sure you have blogs that you never published.
There are some I've drafted that is like shit that can't go out the door.
Not because the writing wasn't good, but because it was way too personal.
Yeah. And it was more for me than it was for other people.
So that's definitely why I started writing again.
And also for humor, I felt like, you know, when you're publishing
on a corporate blog, you cannot be your authentic self.
And I I was like, you know what?
I want to be my authentic self and find my people right
in the direction of your people.
What's hilarious is you started writing
shortly after that again, I think.
And I think I started writing pretty much weekly, minus hiking trips.
Maybe four or five years ago now.
I remember it was it was a New Year's Eve post
and said, I'm going to start writing again.
It was like four or five anyway. Yes.
Yeah. Well, we started writing about similar topics
in similar themes.
And I was like, that's weird.
And then eventually I realized that you all your posts were Taylor Swift songs.
And I think I got to tell them this.
But that got me sticking with it.
Honestly, there was a point there where I almost gave up on writing again.
And you you published a blog and I was like, damn it, I got to do it.
For some reason, I had read so many of your blogs at that point
that that you had become without lack of a better term,
a kind of mentor for me, a digital mentor, if you will.
And I just was like, you know what?
If Alan Page can do it, I can do it.
I gave myself a break when I had a toddler, though, man.
But yeah, yeah, just totally wrecked my schedule
in a way that I could not fully adapt to.
I remember those days.
Yeah, I was too tired to write at that point.
I don't know what would have come out either.
Maybe I should have tried because it would have been funny.
But yeah, anyway, your blog
has always inspired me.
Pitch pitching that put a link to it in here.
You can't put a link in a podcast, can you?
You put it. I can put it in.
I can put it in the notes.
So yes, I will.
Any contact information, follow information put in the notes.
So a couple of things worth calling out.
One, yes, for my first year of blogging,
the title of every weekly blog post was the title of Taylor Swift's song.
And Molly got it right away.
And she bet me that somebody else would get it for sure.
But nobody did.
One person afterwards said, Oh, I thought it was so obvious.
I didn't even bring it up.
They're probably right.
But the then of people who know Taylor Swift songs and
and my readers is very, very tiny.
Yet it was so fun going through like the Wikipedia page
list of Taylor Swift songs, which which sometimes the title was like perfect.
You just like fit so well, you would never even know.
And sometimes it was a stretch.
Sometimes it was a stretch.
And she has enough music that you can actually do it with, right?
It was fun. She's constantly producing music.
So you're going to pick an artist.
That's pretty good. It was pretty fun.
And but the thing I want to talk about a little bit more is
absolutely I think we're aligned on how we write.
I need to write things down to process.
I do a lot of journaling on my own things, not for blog posts,
just writing things down to help me think about them.
A lot of my blog posts,
probably the majority of them are personal as well.
They're about things I'm thinking about.
And there are things in my relationship
with people around me that also make great leadership topics.
And I can write about I can I one thing I
love to do because it helps me process.
It helps me think about things I'm going through in my own life
is I write about two things at the same time.
The leadership topic will read my leadership
and something going on in my life.
I want to process and learn more about.
And until I start writing that out and then
relate to that, I don't.
I mean, it really, really helps me.
And what a little personal information here is that
in writing, because I process, I learn more about myself.
And the thing that I work on a lot is
I I feel like I have pretty good leadership principles
and people like the way I lead and manage them.
And yet I don't always bring those same principles
to relationships with my friends and family.
I go, how can I walk the talk on both sides?
And I really work on doing that.
And and so when writing about two things,
it's one of the ways I work on making sure that
I can be my authentic self, not just on the podcast,
not just in my blogging, but in every every minute of my life.
And it's it's it's part of growing and learning.
And I work on that a lot.
Yeah. And to your point about what you said,
holding yourself accountable.
I feel like so many times in leadership,
whether you're an IC or a manager, you're tested,
especially the more senior you get in your career.
And you might look back at a moment and say, oh, wow,
that decision I made there or that response I gave was actually against
my personal beliefs or my philosophies of operating.
And and I need to face that in in some way.
That that's one of the ways I've handled that.
And also, sometimes you're trying to get a message out to people
that you couldn't say in the moment, not because you didn't know what to say,
but because they weren't ready to hear it.
Yeah. If that sounds weird, like I know, you know,
you probably have former directs that read your blog. Right.
Absolutely. Yeah.
And you know, you you wish you could have said
some of those things at the time or something like that.
I don't know. It's it's an act of owning your character
for the rest of your career.
It is it is.
And I think, you know, one of the things I think is also similar
between us is we're always trying to learn and grow, whether it's new things,
whether it's technologies or personal growth.
And we and I I want to be the same person at work
as I am at home at home and at work.
So I want to bring my authentic self everywhere I go.
It's one of the things I thought about a lot when I was hiking last summer,
like I when I'm feeling most fully myself, that's when I'm the happiest
and I feel the most settled and grounded and and also ready
to take on anything.
So that's what I'm going to do.
Yeah. So maybe I thought I thought I had to mention about our our blogs,
our our separate blogs.
Alan writes more than me, but I'm trying.
Yeah, I've been I've been trying once a week, except for hiking trips.
And I'm done with those for a while.
I'm not going to talk about where.
But one thing you you mentioned one thing I want to talk about some more.
I am going to join the corporate world again.
And this time I'm going to join the corporate world
as a high level individual contributor.
Or I see I'm going to take a step back from management.
And and this is something I've done throughout my career.
I'll talk about you as well, because I know you've done a little bit of the same
as I've I spent most of my career at Microsoft as individual contributor.
I under bomber, I can there's no NDAs.
Bomber was a shitty leader.
And he did some really smart business decision.
Does that even count as an NDA?
No, I know. No, I guess.
And in other news, the sky is blue and water makes things wet.
So there were forced rankings under bomber,
and we got rid of the five, you know, the five point system
and fire the bottom 20 percent or whatever it was.
But we moved to this.
They moved to a nine box model, but it was a forced percentage nine box model.
So as a manager, you were disincentivized to have a high performing team
because you have you have to put 10 percent of your people in the
potentially to be fired bucket.
And I didn't like that.
So I worked as an I.C.
And a lot of times I worked for especially the last half of my career.
I worked as directors when such took over.
I moved in.
I was in director positions a couple of times throughout my career,
once under bomber. It was fine.
And then once later, and I liked it.
I really enjoyed it.
That's right. At Microsoft, I ran
basically one team's version of infrastructure,
you know, everything from everything from the developer desktop
to the customer desktop, I called it.
And then, of course, at Unity, I started as a director,
went back to being an I.C. for a little while,
went back to being a director and then eventually a V.P.
And then at NBC, I was a V.P.
And I thought after trail, I would go back to being a V.P.
But I found this job that's perfect for me as an I.C.
And I'm really super excited about it.
And I I am looking forward to seeing how well I can affect
or how I affect culture and growth as an I.C.
I've done it before.
I'm excited to do it in a new company and see how well it scales.
But what's your journey been like in managing and I.C.
And and and where were you?
I'll just leave it at that.
What's your journey been like?
I know you've done a little bit of both.
Like, what do you what?
Like, how does that work for you?
And what do you like and dislike?
Like, what are pros and cons for those listening?
So it's what's funny is I feel like the more senior you get in your career,
the more you're like, man, wouldn't be really nice if I didn't have to deal
with people, sorry, if I could just take a break.
And there's this misnomer that, oh, if I go back into an I.C.
role from management, I the people problems get less worse.
And I've actually accepted that.
That's not true.
And that's not true at all.
The people problems still exist.
I'm sorry. They still exist.
It's just a different lens.
And they're both they're both OK.
They're just different ways of working in the same problems.
I will. I do agree with you, by the way, forced perf.
I call it forced perf, even though that's not like
the the term everywhere.
But that stack ranking is is brutal.
And it's still really common in a lot of big companies, unfortunately.
Well, they're say, you know, every year we need to to to determine
who is the lower 15 percent.
And we're going to to do that.
And so managers end up giving the system and they try to find creative
ways to keep their people without like or hire at Microsoft.
It was pretty blatant.
Managers would hire one or two losers for their team.
They would hire internally people on a low growth path
so they could so they could get everybody else in the bucket they wanted them in.
Isn't that sickening?
Talking. Yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean, the other thing I've also seen is like, oh,
who's the person who joined the most recent?
We'll put them as a lower performer because we don't want to like.
Yeah, it's some it's something they can live with.
Right. Or someone can live with that.
You know, I'm just going to you're too new here.
So that's that's why you're the lowest.
That one I've seen a lot because it's the easiest.
But sometimes it's not easy and you have to make a shitty decision.
And that that really grinds on me on the management side.
It's still not living with that very well.
But one thing I will say in terms of being an IC is you have a lot more
ownership over the deliverables and what they look like and the shape
that they look like versus on the management side, you have to give
that ownership out and you just kind of give you give the ships
and they have to steer them is kind of how I look at it.
Because you can't you don't have time to get in there in the weeds like that.
And you shouldn't because that's not that that's not the job.
The job is building a good team and making sure things are getting done.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's funny because I thought I wanted I mean, I still like man.
I still like leading teams yet.
I I didn't expect to want and like this job I'm taking so much.
And I'm excited about it.
And then your story also not ready to talk about it,
but it does sound really it'll be fun.
It'll be fun.
It's really what I do.
I'm going to help. It's really a job in systems thinking.
Your your delivery challenge is a system
and and you don't you don't see it that way.
You think you may think the answer is to add more testing,
but that's not always the answer.
That's what Claude is going to say, though, in a lot of the
I'm on test like three hundred that it's written for game.
I love adding more is better.
More is always better.
And what we as a side, what we want is we don't want more tests.
We want confidence. Yeah.
And we don't know that
we the question is, how do we prove or justify
that more tests is giving us more confidence?
I once had a leader who later became my skill level.
But before he was my skill level, we were doing like a CICD roundtable.
I won't say where is because anyway, he wasn't super into CICD.
And his reasoning was we don't have enough tests.
But I was just like, what the fuck?
See, I excuse my language.
But CICD is the continuous deployment, specifically, not delivery.
Emphasis on the word continuous, not delivery
is about breaking things so that then you can figure out what you need to test.
You don't need more tests because you're always going to land at
when is good enough and when is done.
Yeah. And I was very frustrated by one of my favorite questions
to ask for any team trying to, you know, improve delivery,
whether it's from once a month to once a week or once a week to once a day is
what stops you from doing continuous delivery today?
And they give you a long list of things.
And it doesn't matter whether you do continuous deployment or not,
but start addressing those things in priority or those are your bottlenecks.
What are the things that are stopping you?
So we don't have enough tests.
OK, which that's that.
And you have to dive into that, figure out what tests.
Yeah. Or it's I'm afraid we're going to break things.
It's like you are going to break things.
The point is to break them in smaller increments so that it's not either
noticeable at all or and then there's no revenue loss.
Like it's just just defining the blast radius.
I'm sorry. I get really passionate about it.
Even back at my Microsoft job, one of the smart things we did
in my in my job, I think, was we deployed as continuous as we could.
Some of the back the back end, the front end was was sort of a once a week thing.
I don't know if it's that anymore or not.
It's a long time ago.
And what we did was everything deployed
continuously to to a IP address range that was my team.
And so we always had like we always had that.
And then a little wider one went to all of the organization
and a little wider one went to all of Microsoft.
It's great when you have, you know, one hundred thousand internal users.
That's that's pretty handy.
And then a little wider one went to the early adopters, betas,
betas, what the fuck are betas, betas,
people who willing to accept some risk to try the newest.
There's always those out there.
And one of the advantages working in a large company is you have a large
sample size to work with, but you can use deployment strategies as well.
One thing that comes up a lot.
And I mentioned this in our slack group.
You can go you can go to moderntesting.org and join our slack group.
But I I in my time off trail, I wrote a book on modern testing.
And it's with the editors right now.
I have a cover for it.
Just I saw a sample of it today.
I'm excited about it.
And it's funny, one of the things I brought up,
because I just brought up generic problems, how they get solved.
The it's how your system affects.
I forget the subtitles not in front of me, but it doesn't matter.
It's about systems and how taking it back, seeing the system,
not trying to add more tests or try and build confidence in fake ways.
One of the things that comes up a lot.
This has come up for as long as I've been in services is environments
and, oh, we need our testing environment or our staging environment
or our smoke environment or environment.
Two hundred and twelve isn't stable.
We need to work a focus on stabilize that environment.
And I don't know what your philosophy is, but yeah, either.
Actually, I'm going to ask you to help me with my new job.
When I see environment problems.
Yeah, you can go fix those and find out a little bit at a time
and make them align.
You will never match any of your internal environments
to a production of our customer.
No, yeah, no.
So what I write about on my what I've written about a lot on my blog
is it's called Sev One Party for that reason, which is that
I actually believe in getting things into production as fast as possible
and that everything is production from if you treat everything as production,
then you're going to design your systems really differently.
Yeah. So instead of saying, oh, we have seven environments.
One is for just the executive level and one is for QA.
I had one team where I had seven environments
because we wanted a separate environment for investors
and we want a separate environment for the executive suite
where there couldn't be any bugs.
And this is this is years ago.
And I've changed one.
I didn't like that then.
But I hate that now.
You have you you asked me to do that.
I'd be like, hell no.
Hell no. Get out of the belief that there's no bugs.
There's going to be bugs.
And the question is, do users give a shit about them?
That's question number one.
Two, what is their impact?
But yeah, to your point,
I think the faster you get to production, the better.
And then isolate in production.
It's kind of what the model that you said your was essentially
a cell based blast radius of customers internally.
Right. So that's still production or something.
And then again, going back to the question about what's blocking
doing CD, well, things may fail in production.
OK, how can you know if they're failing?
So let's get the right monitoring and telemetry.
Let's build automatic rollback.
If any of the revenue streams go down,
those are all possible things that many, many companies.
Have you heard of a canary?
Not not you, but I'm saying, I know, I know.
That's the thing that that always kills me.
Like we don't test and prod.
I'm like, what? That's what a canary releases.
It's testing in production.
You release the one percent actually do zero and then skip to a one percent
and then 20, 25, whatever.
And then we in teams I've been on,
we have tests running continuously in production
that will flag like any revenue streams impacted.
There's an immediate, as I said, one alert and an ideally automated
rollback or something quick.
But it's you reduce the impact or the blast radius.
And then for those people who insist they need to test something on
a production like environment, I try and come up.
And again, it depends on the company and how they're deployed
and what things look like.
But some sort of ephemeral environment using like Minikube or Docker
or something some way they can do a fake end to end one
that is consistent across machines.
So they can do some they can do a little bit of their their
air quotes again, end to end testing of their service environment.
And again, because they want confidence
and we want to give them opportunities to get confidence.
But we're going to get the most confidence from
actually testing those things in production.
So one of the things on my docket for my current job
and my manager's listening now, he knows my my my secret strategy
is to fix the environment.
But I want to fix them by making them go away.
But and I'm plus one support.
You know, you know, my my blog, my favorite line is disappoint
people the level they can absorb.
Maybe I have to fix them a little bit while they're going away.
It's going to be a little bit of a juggling act.
Yeah, it's better to know that going in, though,
and being like, this is my this is what I stand for
and this is what I believe.
And I've seen it work, which is where I'm at in my career.
Now, I don't have time to kind of beat around the bush
when I like, you know, the problems are with these.
If we what's the if if nothing changes,
this is what happens if nothing changes.
You have worser, longer, more impactful incidents.
Yeah, that's that's the opposite in the equation,
which I've which I've seen.
I've seen and fixed.
And I'm definitely over that.
And my favorite thing, too, is like some people think
they only need to declare an incident when they're losing money
or when they're seeing latency.
The stuff I've always instilled in my teams
is declaring incidents when you think there is impact
that could have repercussions.
And we would live mitigate stuff because that's what infrastructure
incidents look like.
You can be like, look, there somebody started
shipping a bunch more logs than we are usually handling.
We're going to add 50 more 50 more nodes than we need
because we we're having trouble at the other end of the pipeline
until that gets fixed or reverted.
Because we may not want to change. Right.
Yeah. We had such a good culture of exactly that at Unity.
One of the things I loved that I really worked hard on
because I also managed our site reliability team and and incidents.
And we would have development teams open
and they'd open an incident channel.
For instance, we had a command that would open a Slack channel,
invite the right people on call, blah, blah, blah.
They would open an incident channel because they had a complex
deployment coming up the next day or the day after,
and they wanted to be able to talk about it in real time
as it was going out with with proper with adult supervision.
And it was great.
Like, there's no incident, but it was just a way of raising risk.
It was like, yeah, yeah.
But it was because our incident channels were a safe place
to talk about what's going on, what's going wrong.
And and 90 percent of the time, those deployments went without a hitch.
But also they had SRE in the channel, helping them
look at some of the overall monitoring of the system,
how their system may affect other system.
They could ask questions around, you know, whatever is going on.
And also in real time, work with the development team.
I'm building the run book for that service during the, you know,
which completing it while it was being rolled out.
They could ask questions like, OK, if this fails, what do we do?
And all those questions that going back to those questions
that sometimes we forget to ask ourselves
because we're excited to get the new thing out to people and and and be the hero.
I so this is funny because I thought maybe I was the only one
who had ever done a proactive incident.
And now that I'm hearing that that happened at uni and I'm like,
oh, I feel good about it now.
Not not just me, like I think it's a great practice. Yes.
There was a time at a company where we were about to go into a holiday season
and this other manager, I could not convince them to let me
to let my team scale the infrastructure up.
And so I put in an incident.
I said, it's going to fall over if we don't.
And it happened because the incident was the qualifier
to make sure it absolutely happened.
I didn't want to do that, though, you know,
in an ideal world, you could just talk about it, but sometimes.
And our teams, of course, spread across the world.
So Slack channels are free, basically.
And so we would spin one up.
And then we also used
I think they stopped paying for it when I left, but
we use Jelly as it and there's probably other tools to do this now, too.
I'm a big fan of Nora and her work, and they were acquired by PagerDuty.
So I think she's happy there.
But Jelly was this great tool for analyzing Slack channels
and helping you really get the learning out of the incident channel
and separating the fluff out of there.
And the thing I like about the proactive instance,
the regular instance, all of them, it's not about
recognizing the failure, it's about learning.
But what do we learn from this and making sure you have people
in those incident channels to ask those questions, to ensure learning's going on.
And that goes back to psychological safety and being able to make mistakes.
And with the proactive one, people say, hey, we may be making a mistake here.
So we're going to we're going to monitor this.
But their goal really was to make sure they learned from that deployment.
So the next time they had a complex set of features to deploy,
they would have they would know more questions to ask
and have more going back to confidence, have more confidence about
what was getting deployed.
And that so one segue that I want to wrap up here.
But Jason Arbin, hey, Jason, I know you listen.
Thanks for listening.
He just wrote a book on testing and I I'm part way through it.
I've been busy. Sorry, Jason.
I went and hiked.
But one thing I'm not sure I agree with them on, despite my language,
is he thinks that test engineering and I
I'll give my thought on this test engineering may go away
because I can write our test for us.
And I think the role of testers is going to be a lot more diagnostic
and monitoring tools anyway.
But he is a big fan of this term called confidence engineering.
Like we need engineers who can instill confidence.
And that's in the past.
We've done tests for that.
So I get where he's going from.
And I just think we need systems thinkers versus confidence engineers.
But I'm just kind of curious on your take on this,
his idea of confidence engineering, given the vast description
I've given you of it, which is tense.
I think it's a renaming of something that already exists.
I think so, too.
That's not but I don't mean that in an offensive way.
I don't either.
And it's how do you guarantee something so nebulous is another piece.
You get into the woodwork of saying this will guarantee confidence
and confidence is only guaranteed by the customer. Right.
That's modern testing principle.
Number five, quality and people.
This is the most controversial one.
People, you know, the customer determines quality.
The customer determines how well it solves their problem.
Oh, no, I need to do that.
Can't you're not the customer.
So I think that there is something to that.
I think that's a challenge with going back to AI.
We need to we're trying to instill confidence
in these systems that are largely non-human written now.
And it's not just more tests.
It's definitely not more tests.
I think spend a whole another hour talking about it.
So which is my closing that topic.
But I think analysis tools are I think it's the analysis tools
that I really I really are going to step up anyway.
Can I can I have one thing?
Yeah. So we both read a lot of books.
One of the books that I think you've also read
had a story about how oyster sauce was made in it,
which was oyster sauce was not invented.
It was like someone left a bunch of oysters on the stove
and burned them down into a sauce
and just decided to test it.
And it became a multi-billion dollar industry.
This is how I think about the future
and where DevOps has come to.
It's like we've got to stop looking at failure
like it's not an opportunity.
Because if if if you think about these things
as opportunities, then why does confidence matter?
Just get it out there.
Get it out there.
I think the confidence comes from the ability to
confidence is no matter how bad I screw this up.
It's recoverable and it's not going to
it's not going to impact our business in a meaningful way.
Yes. Yes.
If that's the definition of confidence.
Yes, I I agree.
I like that one.
And it's hard people.
A lot of companies, there's this fear of making mistakes
and we need the opposite more than ever
because the mistakes now are inevitable
and largely out of our control.
Yeah.
Oh, the robots are taking over and we're all going to die.
He made a Volcker reference.
What is it?
I forget the the acronym for complexity or.
Yeah.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah, I've forgotten a lot of things.
Actually, we'll say one thing.
My biggest worry about going back to work is
I don't know.
I've forgotten how to work like an eight hour day.
I'm sure I'm sure it'll hit you like a ton of bricks.
Like I write for an hour and a half or two hours
and I'm fried.
I need a nap.
I'm not sure how to.
I'm sure what it's going to be like.
Anyway, what what didn't we talk about
that we should talk about in our last few minutes here?
Everything that isn't going to get us another hour of content.
Oh, yeah, that happened.
OK, name dropped a bunch of good stuff
that people should go look at.
We should go check it out.
Yeah, and I'm going to drop in the show notes.
I'll drop a link to your blog and anything else.
Let me know.
But Molly, well, one, it's just great to talk to you in general.
Yeah, it's been a while.
It's good to catch up.
And then two, I well, part of it just stroking my own ego
because I love to talk to smart people
who agree with me a lot.
So that makes me feel good about myself.
I was going to say you are not the person I would go to
if I need like an anti voice.
We think too much alike.
You obviously have more experience than I do.
But yeah, if I need like an anti person,
I got to talk to somebody else.
Yeah, yeah.
But it's also we also enjoy just venting at each other, too.
So which is always fun.
Anyway, great to talk to you.
Great, great time on the podcast.
It's about time we got you on here.
Good luck in your job search and find a job.
You know this advice because we think alike,
but find it for anyone looking for a job.
It's hard in this economy.
I'll take any job I can get.
I can't pay the rent.
That's not the case with you.
I think people like you can be selective
and find a job that you both excites you
and you love and will energize you.
I have decided that like from it is the same way.
I am never going to work one day.
I'm taking this new job I'm super excited about.
I have maybe not on the first bad day,
but if there's any smells about it, I'm probably gone.
I've done this too long to work some.
I don't think it's going to be the case,
but I we should we should find jobs that we love
and energize us and that we like.
And I know you will.
And even even in the the tiny remote town of Atlanta,
which has a huge, huge tech and movie.
You know, those of you don't know,
Atlanta's pretty big in the tech.
And it's actually a good place for jobs.
Time is the most valuable currency we have
and you never get more of it.
It is.
And it's also the the the finite one.
Yes, we all get the same 24.01 hours, whatever it is a day.
All right, I got I got to play the outro and get going here.
But Molly, thanks again for being on.
And this has been episode, I don't know,
236 of the A.B. testing podcast.